Stone Cold Steve Austin right here on
the Rich Eisen show the two night season
finale of his unique interview show on a
USA Network straight-up Steve Austin
kicks off tonight at 11:00 Eastern Time
good to see you Steve Austin how you
doing I'm doing good man perfect day for
you to be here well any day is a great
day for you to be here perfect day for
you to be here because Baker Mayfield is
gonna be front and center on ESPN
tonight and he was one of your guests on
your show what was your impression of
Baker when you met him guys young enough
to be my son if he was my son I'd be
proud to call him one I thought a whole
lot of the kid before I met him and then
spending all day it takes a long time to
film the show I hung out with this guy
all day long and at the facility right
yeah I got a chance to meet coach
kitchens and a lot of guys when I walked
in i was going to a training room I saw
Myles Garrett back here and of course
I'm a big Texas A&M guy all stuff text
is all stuff football Sir Walter said
hey man would that miles Garrett and
they said yeah so I met him as well he's
a big he had a great year last year and
he's just a supreme athlete so it's fun
to meet all those guys but Baker's a
class act he thrives under pressure and
lives for those big moments
he never was plan a and until he was
drafted number one by the Cleveland
Browns and I just I think he's the best
have you stayed in touch with him at all
no I you know I just like you know the
Clipper Dale junior you know he's got
this thing going on and I'm doing my
thing I'm bad about staying in contact
with people anyway why is that I don't
know it's just I'm the worst at
returning you know text messages
voicemails emails you name it I'm bad
I'll get a voicemail my wife will say
hey did you return so and so's call us I
said no I said well you didn't listen to
the voicemail listen I know what what
are you gonna listen to it I don't know
whenever I do so I don't know why I do
that but okay that's me I'm I could put
off anything so what's the number of
voicemails that are on your phone right
now
all right now I'm clear you're clear
yeah I'm not that guy that gets all the
storage backed up so you can't leave a
message okay you never you you never
know when that one important phone call
that you've got to have comes so if you
miss later you listening
for you to ignore in a timely fashion at
least you know at least you know that's
fantastic well it's pretty cool I mean
just hanging with Baker obviously on the
outset of a pretty big season and and
the question is as he written checks
that he won't be able to cash and I'm
sure you've come across people where you
know that that's a guy that's Fugazi in
that regard but you didn't get that
sense from him as well I didn't get that
at all and he doesn't take anything for
granted and if he's gonna get an
opportunity he's gonna make the most out
of it last week coming out of the gate
didn't do so great you know team fell
short but they're gonna correct that and
I just I believe in a kid yeah he's
gonna be just fine what was it like
being around an NFL team Steve I'm such
a fan and I've met a lot of those guys
you know in days gone by and a lot of
those guys have been fans of mine and so
just just hanging out with them no I
just love the culture and love the
locker room and when you when you get
there and you get that feel like like
that's their sanctuary Wes that's where
they all go hang and that's where it all
comes together as far as them becoming a
team and doing all things together so
there's a lot of camaraderie there a lot
of pressure on them Cleveland's really
you know hungry for a winning season I
thought they did great last year when
they put Baker in and you know he was
able to break you know Russell Wilson
Peyton Manning's touchdown records right
now play the whole season so they're
gonna be fine Stone Cold Steve Austin
here on the Rich Eisen show is it safe
to say the Cowboys are your team or now
I have been a Cowboys fan you know here
and there
always love Troy Aikman but my guy back
in the day was Terry Bradshaw I was a
Steelers fan you know watched up the
Lynn Swann and Stallworth and watch the
Franco Harris and Rocky Bleier and me
and Joe Greene and all those guys Mel
Blount on defense I was a big I was a
big Steel Curtain guy well I would love
to see branch on your show I mean have
you ever had him even on your pod cuz I
would think the two of you together
would just be must-see or must hear TV
or radio I got a chance just two days
ago to watch his a football life of him
yeah and I always knew that he was from
Louisiana but that's all I knew I didn't
know he is big in the raisin
Championship horses what kind of
background he
from and man he was the wrong kind of
guy to be coached by a Chuck Noll
because he was that guy that responded
to positive response and that's why it's
high school coaches say that's alright
Terry or his lot of tech coaches hey man
we're good we're good
ok any time you know I always kept him
up and Chuck know kind of stayed on his
on his ass yeah yeah he didn't respond
to that so well and so they had that
very strained weird relationship but
still won four Super Bowls together
absolutely you know Steve Austin here on
the Rich Eisen show ok so what were you
like at the University of North Texas
that got a you got a full scholarship to
play football there what were you like
in your in your days highly competitive
rich but you know that was big back when
North Texas was a division to school
they're Division one now uh-huh
we were out to run in 40s and I came
from you know junior college and and in
high school I was running back in a
linebacker and I wasn't fast enough to
run around you so I ran over you and so
we're out there running 40s and Corky
Nelson was our coach at North Texas and
we're out there running and my last name
used to be Williams and he's gonna got
this perplexed look on his face he goes
Williams come here maybe I said yeah
coach what you want
he goes you're running a 4 9 I said yeah
oh he's running a 4 9 he goes your coach
award and said you ran a 4 7 I said
coach I ain't never had a 4 7 in my life
Williams get out of here so I was that
guy from from me to you quickest guy on
a team if there's a sandwich or a beer
involved you know but it wants you to
start stretching out Bassett I blew my
ACL out on a kickoff coverage about the
third game of my junior seasons ya know
season rehab and came back and started
all 11 games next year at weak side
defensive end a little undersized you
know started not really a discipline
player yeah and as much as I love
football and pro football hell I wasn't
even close to making the grade ok so the
most talented athlete you were ever in
the ring with would be who man where'd
like ok this this person can really move
around or this person can really do this
or whatever Ron Simmons why is that it
was two-time all-american to Florida
State University diva defensive tackle I
mean why he didn't play profile
I don't know but that guy they still
know who Ron Simmons is at Florida State
and then you could go to you know Kurt
Angle who won a gold medal in the 96
Olympics with a broken neck and then
from a strength standpoint Mark Henry
the World's Strongest Man
I mean he's legitimately the world or
was you know the World's Strongest Man
so guys like that there's there's so
many physical specimens in that line of
work it's unbelievable yeah right well
obviously you're one of them I mean who
named you Steve Austin where'd you come
up with that I was Steve Williams and in
Dallas Texas when I was getting my start
I went to Tennessee the Booker was a guy
named Dutch Mantell I I drove my 1988
high-end a excel over there to the
mid-south Coliseum and I walk in to I've
been in business 3 months and I walk in
and back in the old days there was a guy
from University of Oklahoma named dr.
death Steve Williams so I couldn't use
that name because it would cause
confusion on the card so Dutch Mantell
looks at me and says all right you're
Steve Austin and I said well I don't
want to be Steve Austin because I had
respected the Six Million Dollar Man and
I didn't want to copy that that's sure
so he goes you got 15 minutes come up
with a name so 15 minutes goes by I
couldn't come up with nothing
he says you're Steve Austin I said no he
goes you got five minutes come up with a
name this is right before I'm fixin to
go out rich you know that your last name
your whole name has a big effect on your
career horse so finally he says you know
basically get your ass out there you're
Steve Austin and that's how I got it
that's how it has nothing to do the fact
that you're from Austin and I always
said I was from Victoria Texas which is
a town I used to live in okay but if I
would have said Steve Austin from Austin
Texas you know two redundant no no real
panache a ring to it so when I finally
came up with that Stone Cold Steve
Austin thing I told him I said I want to
be from Victoria Texas because I wanted
to be opposite of everybody else who
wanted to be from a big city you know
and with a lot of glamour to it huh so
that's how it has its I mean it's kind
of what Texas had a little bit of you
not say quad to it and I was like hey
man that sounds kind of cool where is it
well I understand because I mean if
there's a similarity here is that when I
was first trying to get on TV
I had a resume reel from North
Western School of Journalism Medill
School of Journalism so I grew up my
parents still call me Richard but I
wasn't gonna be a sportscaster
Richard Eisen and the question was you
know my high school they were calling me
Ritchie I'm like here's Ritchie with
sports and then the the one thing that
definitely I would not I wasn't gonna go
with dick Eisen I just wasn't gonna go
with that it's just even though Enberg
did very well what that name just didn't
fit so I went with Rich and that was
kind of it but there's got to be that
kind of thing that you understand I'm
looking at right there and your logo
yeah it looks right and sounds right it
is right that is it is right Steve
Austin few more minutes left with Steve
Austin here on the Rich Eisen show so
what was it like being back in Madison
Square Garden
it had to be amazing it was fun because
I didn't realize it been so long since
I'd been how long had someone said I did
a piece of business there no.4 but
before that actively wrestling and
sometime in the late 90s and so going
back it was very special the garden is
considered the backyard for Debbie w/e
because they're based out of Stanford
Connecticut and that's you know sure the
backyard it just it just is the way it
is
and so that's such an important market
to Vince McMahon and so personal to him
on many levels he always showed up at
that show and and whether it was just a
house show or television taping or a
pay-per-view and a house show is simply
a show that's at an arena where there's
not cameras rolling mm-hmm and so we
used to thrive on that and spend close
to 300 days a year out on the road but
Vincent always go to that show and when
you knew Vince was there everybody was
working their tails off to begin with
but when they knew Vince was there and
that could affect you know based on the
crowds response to you and how you
performed in a ring you might be in line
to get moved further up the card if you
resonated with the fans and you saw
Vince McMahon saw you work so a very
special place and the garden is such a
tough crowd to get over with because
they've seen and heard everything rich
history of wrestling there so I thought
you're talking about the Knicks
it's a tough crowd
sure and if you can get over from that
crowd they will love you or hate you or
respect you for the rest of your career
do you have any good memories
Madison Square Garden
yeah well go back to a match I had with
Brent the Hitman Hart who meant so much
to my career because he hand-picked me
to come back from a knee injury that he
was coming back from and so we had a
really solid match but other than that
you know working a high-profile match at
SummerSlam called highway to hell with
the Undertaker in which for the first
time in my life I was knocked out and
knocked out in the middle of a match in
front of 20,000 people live on
pay-per-view and I remember when I got
knocked down I was laying there on the
mat and I looked up and an early heaven
of the referees looking down he goes god
dangit
and I looked up at him and I see him and
I see the ceiling - Madison Square
Garden I said where am I he goes got
dagger boy you in the garden
I'll never forget it yeah never forget
it and I don't remember the rest of the
match but I did it yeah that was that
what that was something I'll never
forget
or is it possibly gonna have anything to
do with the XFL reboot you can do
anything with them well I haven't been
asked her I've talked about it to
anybody but it's gonna be real
interesting to see because I was really
in the trenches hot and heavy
back when XFL first started years ago
and I know you know Vince wanted another
season because he thought it could have
worked but they ended up pulling the
plug and I think it left a sour taste in
his mouth so now all these years removed
here they come back so I'm very
interested in it and to see how it's
gonna do and I'm a I'm a football junkie
rich but it's gonna be very interesting
I've agree with that what was what were
you doing for the XFL the first time
around what were you doing for those who
might not remember basically just
because all those jerseys kind of fit my
motif as far as dressing right wearing
all the jerseys through all the airports
because that's that's kind of the stuff
that I wear I didn't really go to
actively promote the games because we
were on the road so much sure I just
remembered that we we probably funded a
lot of that based on our stuff I mean in
the days of now where Twitter Instagram
and there's so many different ways
you're clearly pointing that out I mean
your your show that's gonna be airing
tonight first of two nights for your
season finale on USA your podcast I mean
you have a ton of followers and you are
as a first great influencer resort could
possibly be it would make sense to have
somebody like you be part of a reboot of
the XFL Steve I'm just throwing that out
there I don't want any pie don't want
any Commission I'm not gonna expect any
but I'm just don't so you would you
would be part you wouldn't want to be
part of that I don't know you know it's
funny because Richie as close as you are
to the game are you an X's and O's guy
because like I love to watch the guys
you know on Fox Sports or wherever it is
you want to bring or an ESPN breaking
down the games and talking about the
matchups because I just still see a
football game and when I hear those
analysts break down you know the the
matchups and how you know this team has
an advantage this week based on you know
what everybody's bringing to watch those
guys had played so long to break down a
game i I'm not capable of doing that
well I just go on a gut instinct and say
hey man I think Cowboys gonna beat the
trash I'm just thinking you should be
part you should be just sticking on the
sidelines at the very least if it's
something you'd want to do or something
that'd just be part of it it was
scheduled at Steve Austin BSR on Twitter
and Instagram and tonight straight up
Steve Austin tonight's season finale
starting at 11:00 Eastern Time
how have you enjoyed just the the making
a television show and having a
conversation with people that you'd like
to talk to it was it was a great
experience and we shot the pilot
tonight's episode is Trace Adkins a
little over a year ago we flew him into
LA and you know in a season one of
anything much less a pilot you kind of
throwing stuff at the wall and seeing
what sticks and me coming from the world
I come from trying to find myself who
and what I am as an interviewer you know
as far as the energy you're bringing or
what whatnot so it was a real experiment
and I finally got some momentum going
and then all of a sudden you film you
know the six episodes after the Tres
episode and you're done so it was a very
interesting experience I had a blast
doing it learned a lot special from now
seeing the show edited together to get
the beats together sure so I'm
forward - I anticipate a season -
although that has not been confirmed
okay so maybe season two of of your show
season 2.0 of the XFL what else can we
work on for you here Steve let's let's
figure it out good if you just said you
do my podcast I will do that I will do
that do you cook
it's like a Steve Austin cooking show or
something like that I do cook but I'm
like that protein guy man it's always
gonna be on a grill I happen to be
married to a woman who is vegetarian
first vegetarian I ever met in my life
but she loves to cook so I got to keep
my carcass out of the kitchen because
that's her Zen space so you say it's
your first is it your only vegetarian
you've ever come across yes
hey man it's 15 years ago rich in South
Texas when you roll up to McDonald's and
I'm oh I'm ordering about you know six
quarter pounders with cheese and she
orders a mikvah G burger and they're
like what do you mean do you just not
want to put a patty in it because in LA
they had them at the time so she ate a
lot of salads down in South Texas and
she wasn't digging it's just a burger
without the meat probably about the same
fixins do you not want the patty in it
that is hilarious 11:00 Eastern tonight
on USA Network the first of a two night
season finale of straight-up Steve
Austin on USA and then the Steve Austin
show podcast on podcast 1 great to see
you man thank you back time you know
that and any and absolutely I'm thrilled
to have you that's at Steve Austin BSR
on both Twitter and Instagram for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app